I think what I had heard was you said
something like Maxine was the best of
this the three scripts and I was
wondering if you could tease like not
story specifics of course but but what
feeling does that have that makes it the
best of the three because you know how
much I love X and pearl so it's hard to
imagine getting something better
yeah I mean
say it's uh
it's just such a fun film I I Tai really
I I mean I don't know how he does it
he's just able to
come up with these worlds and it's just
the biggest of the of the three movies
the stakes are the highest and you know
Maxine has been through so much at this
point and she's just such a badass
character in he's not the kind of person
that you want to to cross the wrong way
and so you know she's gonna protect
you know what she has and it's just uh
it's a wild it's gonna be I don't know I
really don't know what I can say without
but it's my favorite script of the three
you probably can't answer this but I'll
at least try because you use the word
big do you mean in terms of scope
because the other two films felt so
contained to that property for the most
part at least yeah the it's uh
the biggest Stakes the biggest world
it's uh I really don't know I should
have I feel about you right now so much
I should have probably thought about
this a little more but I it's I'm very
excited I'm in the middle of prep and
it's I'm having a lot of fun with it